so what I'm going to do is just
introduce this we're going to continue
it in future lessons but I just want to
give you the basics and then you
actually have the opportunity to chip
away at some basic questions sorry I
snuck this on when you weren't looking
that's taught me okay so with stationary
points we really have two key questions
that get asked of you over and over
again the two questions in plain
language are hey the stationary points
where are they like for some function I
want you to tell me where they are their
location and then secondly once you know
where they are can you tell me what kind
of stationary points are they okay now
you'll see particular words that go with
these more technical language than this
and they will say to say where are they
they all say locate this stationary
points okay by which they mean can you
tell us the coordinates right it's like
oh it's at 1 comma 2 that's where you're
stationary point is or 0 0 at the origin
there's a stationary point there that's
the keyword you will often see and up in
a question locate the stationary points
which means an X and a 1 and I'll write
that down as well ok but after you
locate the next thing they'll ask you is
tell me what kind of a stationary point
is you can see we've got all different
kinds right and the technical language
they use for that is can you determine
the nature of the stationary points tell
me what variety is can you categorize I
know it's stationary there but then like
it's like what's happening around it ok
does it does it turn around is it isn't
one of these guys like it just stops for
a moment then it just keeps on going in
the same direction so that's what they
will ask ok now you've already actually
had a go at some of this some locating
business so let's just give you an
example and we'll just do the one based
on the time
I'm okay sir if I gave you this function
right and asked you
hey stationary points I'd like you to
tell me where they are and then tell me
what kind of stationary points they want
they actually turn out to be right the
first thing we're going to do is find
where the derivative is equal to zero
right that's the common thing between
all of these different kinds of points
even though they're all quite diverse
they will all have a derivative of zero
at that particular spot okay so I need a
derivative so can we differentiate this
together please
what are yet I could use a question rule
if I wanted to like open crack an egg
with a hammer but don't need to have a
look it's going to be three x squared
over three which I think you can work
out is just x squared and then what
happens this guy minus four
okay good I'm differentiating ya write
it down for now and come back to it this
is something you're gonna need to be
able to do kind of in the background
okay now this next part is really
important we keep on saying we keep
droning on and on right you're working
out the way you set it out is critical
right so the next thing I want to do is
to find the stationary points is I want
to know when this thing is equal to zero
and I'm going to say that that's what
I'm doing okay so to locate stationary
points to locate stationary points let's
D Y on DX equals zero now I'm gonna tell
you right now like 90% of you are going
to go straight to writing this line
especially the more and more you do this
question like you have to do this a lot
you're gonna do a thousands of times
before the end of the HSC okay so you're
gonna get tired of writing this okay now
I'm just gonna go out there and tell you
you really need to say this because this
statements gonna appear just out of
nowhere yep let's I out isn't it very
miss y'all I'll wear that I was riding
in a hurry okay now the reason why I'm
making such a big deal about this is if
this is the next line of working dy/dx
equals zero and just that's it it's
wrong because dy/dx is not just equal to
zero do you why
X is equal to that it's a function it
changes value it does different things
at different times that's the whole
point of is doing this right so you
can't just say this as a categorical
statement you've got to say it because
you're doing something else okay
this is the context that makes sense of
this and now I can actually go ahead and
solve it I know what the derivative is
it's x squared minus 1 so that's x
squared minus 4 equals 0 now I've picked
out a nice easy function for you because
hopefully you can help me out by working
on what the values are there's two of
them you can give you that for free it's
going to be two and negative two the way
you work that out is you've got two
choices you could have added 4 to both
sides and then you're like ah what's the
number I squared to get for that one of
what I generally prefer to factorize
because it makes it more obvious that
there are two solutions one from each
factor so X will equal negative 2 or 2
awesomitude
okay look back right at the top of the
page whilst I am stall and what type of
synthesis so I have more working space
have I answered the question and said
where the stationary points are and the
answer is no I half have 1/2 half right
what am I missing
I'm missing a Y value right so this is
the equivalent of me saying you know
like where is cheerio technology high
school the answer is purchase road so I
give but where I'm purchase Road right
so you need more detail in there I need
I need Y values to go with this how do I
am how do I find those how do I find
those Y values I'm substituting I'm
substituting these into into we're into
the original function thank you very
much ok so I'm gonna go up to here I'm
gonna say when x equals negative 2 when
x equals negative 2 y equals 2 and then
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm going to
substitute ok this looks to me like
negative 8 on 3 - 4 lots of negative 2
so this is negative 8 on 3 plus 8 which
is plus 24 on 3 is that 16 on 3 yeah
don't probably mean me I probably got it
wrong so tell me if I got it right are
you happy
ok good ok so this this is a Y value
right so there
what I can do is I can combine these two
together and I can say this guy here
negative 216 over three that's one of my
stationary points okay
I need to find the other one so I'm
going to do the other substitution when
x equals two and I'm going to repeat the
process okay
so y equals 8 over 3 take away 8 this is
looking like the same thing bit opposite
that right same P mat opposite
everything's going negative so I guess
that means it's negative 16 every 3 yeah
happy so I have another point 2 comma
negative 16 over 3 okay